unpleasant story the saarne of trial
interesting that you know the
conservatives always want to try
terrorists as a military combatant and
yet even though our criminal justice
system sucks so often in so many cases
the one place where it's really good is
convicting terrorists and we see it
again with tsarnaev juries pretty much
get it when it's a terrorist up there so
I don't think the concern of
conservatives is that you're not going
to convict the terrorists I think it's
an issue about intelligence gathering
and sources and and obviously
interrogation issues which were probably
less of an issue with the tsarnaev's
because they did seem to be more lone
actors than it would have been in a case
with somebody out of al-qaeda or Isis
but in general they I think
conservatives assume that if you get
Khalid Sheikh Mohammed or Osama bin
Laden in front of a jury the trial might
end up being a circus but they are going
to get convicted well I've heard an
awful lot of conservatives favor
military tribunals over civilian courts
right I'm just no I'm just saying it's
because mostly because of intelligence
gathering issues I think well the
Conservatives I know but these are not
the conservatives I know okay but so now
we come to the part of what are we going
to do with this guy
are we going to kill him now I've always
been okay with the death penalty not if
there's any doubt but this is one of
those no doubters his own lawyer said
you did it but I have a problem with
giving this guy what he wants you know
they kept saying that he was he looked
arrogant and he looked indifferent I
think they're misinterpreting that what
he looked to me was confident confident
because he knew where he was going up to
paradise which gets us back to the idea
of Islam is the mother lode of bad ideas
for Reid well as
as you know bill I've written a lot
about the problems in Islam in fact I
wrote about them well before you were
talking about it because I was focused
on that stuff my problem with the way
you approach it is I don't think you're
going to reform a religion by telling
1.6 billion people most of whom are just
devout people who get some inspiration
from that religion and go about their
their daily lives I don't think you're
going to change the religion by saying
your religion is the mother lode of bad
ideas it's a terrible thing you know
shape it up and change it I think I
think frankly you're going to make a lot
of news for yourself and you're going to
get a lot of applause lines and joke
lines out of it but if you really want
to change that those people if you want
to change that religion then what you
have to do is push for reform but also
with some sense of respect for what the
spiritual values that people take I'm
not a religious guy but all I'm telling
you is I know that word and if you tell
everybody you suck your religion sucks
clean it up
think it's going to get that back so I
should so let's let's say it's not even
a religion let's say there's a social
club that believe is women are
second-class citizens gay people should
be put to death you should be put to
death that's not all 1.6 billion people
not all they did if they not all that
way not you have a lot more than a few
Terry you do know for Reid come on you
do not in that same Pew survey that you
quote every time you this comes up and
I'm not disputing it I know this beauty
I'm not disputing it one one time four
years ago pew did the survey and they
got those so you're saying in the world
it is not a widespread belief that death
is the appropriate response to I don't
think I don't know because I didn't
conduct that for all I'm tell you is
that you go to those countries you go to
Indonesia the largest Muslim country in
the world and they have lived happily
with minorities you know women are given
respect yes is it as advanced as the
West no you don't have a huge problem of
jihad the biggest problems you have are
in pathologically dysfunctional Arab
societies which have had 40 or 50 years
of repressive dictatorships in which
they have driven all dissent in to the
most extreme places but I but I began by
saying I have always said there is a cat
the word I've used as there is a cancer
with
in Islam our difference is how are you
going to fix it
are you I do really think your your can
help your through accommodating people
with our first row without a persuading
people with what you're doing your
you're getting applause lines in the
West you know and if you know that
that's insulting that I'm doing this for
applause well I'm telling you the
reality is you're not changing those
people you know it's not my Egyptian but
let's let's let's think about we started
with tsarnaev right I mean I think one
interesting way to look at this is if he
had had his life experience thirty or
forty years ago and this is a point that
Frida's made in some of his columns he
probably wouldn't have decided to become
a radical jihadi
he would have become some kind of more
secular terrorist if he'd been in
Germany in that era he could have joined
the baader-meinhof gang he could have
done all kinds of things the reality is
that in the West with guys like the
brothers with the people did the Charlie
Hebdo killings in Paris and so on
radical Islam has become the this the
one remaining alternative in a world
where communism is dead fascism is dead
nobody really wants to start a Putin
antenna there are some people who do but
but so while I mean and I agree with you
and freed on your point of common ground
right there is a real cancer in part of
Islam right now and that's part of the
reason that these people are attracted
to it but it's also true that these guys
are it's a mix of sort of people who are
losers and people who are dissatisfied
with modern society and don't have any
other way to act out against it and our
society doesn't offer alternatives to
those people and some of the crazy ones
some stupid ones go and join Isis it
gets back to the bad apples issues very
few bad apples
okay I have to move on si but let's not
pretend that the the things that Isis
believes are not things that many
millions tens of millions hundreds of
millions of Muslims believe around the
world to pretend that is just but to say
that hundreds of millions of people
believe what Isis does you would have a
lot more problems than D then the number
then the terrorist saying that believe
that you should burn people alive I'm
saying they believe that if you make fun
of the Prophet death is what comes to
you you don't you don't agree because I
look I I grew up in this world what
people feel that you know they feel like
their religion is being insulted and so
if you ask them on a poll the point is
do they go around burning people do they
go around stoning people in Indonesia in
India these are places were hundreds of
millions of Muslims live right and all
I'm saying is well you don't see that
and the people who do that if if they if
they know that there are hundreds of
millions of people who support that idea
no I'm not myself going to kill someone
Rushdie but I think it's a terrific idea
somebody does or can't deny that those
are fellow travelers all I'm saying is
the you you don't have any operational
reality there which is those those
countries those societies are not
actually stoning people today
you